قال الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ان
اوكرانيا استخدمت نظام الدفاع الجوي
باتريوت الذي زودتها به الولايات المتحده
لاسقاط طائره نقل عسكريه روسيه من طراز
ايل 76 الاسبوع الماضي في منطقه بكورد
والتي تقول موسكو انها قتلت جميع من كانوا
على متنها وعددهم 74 شخصا وقال بوتين ايضا
ان روسيا مثل اوكرانيا تريد اجراء تحقيق
دولي في
الحادث
ثبت بشكل قاطع ان الطائره اسقطت بواسطه
نظام باتريوت الامريكي وقد حدد ذلك بالفعل
من خلال تحليل الخبراء ازالت السلطات
الاوكرانيه في مكان ما عباره تفيد بانها
ترغب في اجراء تحقيق دولي نحن نطالب بذلك
ونصر على اجراء تحقيق دولي ولا توجد اطراف
راغبه في ذلك من المنظمات الدوليه ان
روسيا تطالب
باجراء مثل هذا
التحقيق